[Music]
everybody to be part of here for Team
Coco I'm outside of Maya Rudolph's
dressing room
let's barge in and see what happens here
we go but hey hello how I just broke my
hand oh it's not that extreme okay I'm
not comfortable doing interviews with
other people in the room can I have you
ask your people to leave adios
no wait or they're gonna hide in the
bathroom you know what that safety first
do you know what there's a risk of a
tornado coming that's what I do
well that's when tornadoes come how many
tornadoes have you been in 12
all right listen let's talk about it get
comfortable girl they're great but I had
no support whatsoever that's all I got
stupid questions to ask you stupid
question you ready look at look how many
I have it can you read that
No so this is gonna be a nightmare okay
I will do that for five dollars you
would I don't know what's the question
do you believe in miracles
miracle or miracle wait what mirror
Gould's I believe in miracles do you
know the way to San Jose do you know the
way to say you just get on the road and
drive have you ever seen the rain coming
down like a game do you you feel like I
do
mmm-hmm Peter Frampton that's right I
want to know what love is I want you to
show me who's zoomin who lose ooh men
who think this all is better read that
over the Franklin end all right retha
probably no problem is that me
I would love to know can you hit the
high C and loving you nope you can't do
it only one lady can and she's not here
even close I'm like a I'm like the
closest thing to a baritone for a lady
when I think I'm like Will Arnett with
boobies I don't how to react to that
you
[Music]